[Music]
hi
everyone it's nona grace and i'm from
western new york
today i'm going to talk about how to
introduce
a new hand to the hen house i had a
comment
that i think it was made by trisha
from becoming me i'll put her link in
and she i guess she's got a couple new
ones that she'd like to add but doesn't
know exactly how you should do it
well when i got dorothy i don't know if
you remember way back
when those of you that have been with me
for a while and when i got dorothy and
her seven babies
i had to introduce her to the hen house
the easiest way
i find to introduce a new hen or any hen
to the hen house
is to put them in a dog crate one of the
large dog crates
it's a wire crate and you put that
in i put that right in with the chicken
run
so that all the chickens can see and
when they're first put in there
everybody's paying a lot of attention to
that hen
in fact they will try to try to get the
hen
and fight with it or pack it
but because there's the dog wires in
between they can't get to the hen
or to the new chicken that's being added
so after a while they kind of like oh
well
that's that's just her she's in there
and they lose interest in her when they
lose
interest which takes about three days
usually
then you can open the door and let the
um hand that's inside out if she wishes
to come out i just open the door and let
her decide when she wants to come out
and she will come out
or if you find that you don't want to do
that my brother has suggested that you
put the hen in the hen house
in the dark because when they wake up
they'll go oh
were you here all the while i don't
remember you but
they'll they'll pay no attention to it
because they'll think that that hen has
always been there just they've never
noticed
but i think they would notice i really
do so i always put them in the little
dog carrier
or a dog crate it's a wire cage
and this way they can't get to them and
when i
introduced little lady i pretty much
had her out there she had the fence
between her like
like mr brown has been doing he goes out
and they see him
but there's some hens that come out of
the
enclosed area in the in the fenced-in
area they've
found a way to come out and they have
mingled with him a little bit or her a
little bit
when they first started doing it they
would peck mr brown
but this last time they didn't pack at
him
they just ate right next to like they
pretended that they didn't even see her
and they were um actually doing
quite well when he went over by the
fence
there was a different hen that was i
think it was dorothy that came over
and another white hen came over and
he did a stare for a little bit and she
did a little bit of staring at him
and then he went about his eating and
she kind of left him alone
so they're getting used to each other i
did get a question to whether i was
going to put mr brown
in with the hens and because i'm going
on vacation
in june i will have to put mr brown in
with the hens so
he'll be outside so that they can see
him
often and this way when i do put him in
he will be
safe and if i have to i can always put
him in a dog
crate just to make sure that he'll be
all right
and that's how you introduce and i have
a message for doyle
doyle i know it doyle had made a comment
about the water thing
when i said you drink your half half of
your weight in
water it's ounces not pounds
or gallons or whatever
that was funny because he was saying
something but he'd have to drink 10
gallons of water
no no no no no if it's your half your
body weight like if you weigh
in and ounces if you weighed 200 pounds
you would drink 100 ounces of water if
you were
one or if you're
one fifty fifty years you drink seventy
five
pounds ounces and not pounds and not
gallons so and i did pretty good today i
drank all of mine i think i've got about
um eight more ounces to go and then i
will have mine completed and the
day i still have a few hours left before
i go to bed
so that's what i wanted to say and i
hope
that if you want to introduce your
chickens to the hen house
that you find it easy going
and i will talk to you all again
tomorrow bye
you